un mois après rma les petits commerces
ont été les premiers à réouvrir le vice
procureur sait qu'ils peuvent être la
cible des voleurs c'est des chinois
c'est pas le même communauté il ya de
l'argent c'est facile awad le jeu on me
prend le temps de récupérer la ferraille
voilà il demande bien à prendre l'argent
qui est en dessous parce qu'ils savent
que commerçants mettent pas tous dans la
caisse
et puis les gens qui sont alentours sont
pas très préoccupé par ce qui se passe
c'est devenu un peu banale que les
supérettes soit soient braqués un
business de la sécurité privée émergent
sur l'île lors de banals contrôles
routiers les gendarmes découvrent
parfois à bord des véhicules des armes à
feu illégales comme ce pistolet
semi-automatique le même utilisé par les
forces de l'ordre
c'est dans la voiture de cet homme qui a
été retrouvé cette arme interdite
j'arrive à la boutique marque lada mark
est un commerçant connu sur l'île il
aurait embauché cet homme pour protéger
son épicerie des voleurs pour assurer
quelques heures par jour la sécurité de
l'épicerie il était payé 1000 dollars
par mois
une offre qui tombait à pic a pris en
main
me look like i'm not there de quelques
jours plus tard nous retrouvons marque
le commerçant qui s'était procuré une
arme illégale pour protéger son épicerie
il a accepté d'être filmés à visage
découvert pour dénoncer le climat
d'insécurité dans le quartier il fait
partie des rares commerçants à avoir été
épargné par les pillages sam était pour
lui un moyen de dissuader les braqueurs
sur des routes ça venait de sauver tous
les fils de l'ex ennemi
il y va y pose pour qu'ils posent
son magasin se trouve dans le quartier
d'orléans un des coins les plus pauvres
du territoire ou 21 % de la population
vit du rsa contre 7 % en ile-de-france
marc a déjà été braqué plusieurs fois
derrière son comptoir le dernier fait
remonte à seulement deux mois avant
leurs mains depuis la série de pillages
c'est désormais dans l'épicerie que marc
a aménagé sa chambre les outils sap est
arrivé juste après yom ha le commerçant
a investi dans un nouveau système de
vidéosurveillance et dans une arme à feu
qu'il a acquise d'une façon particulière
200 $ par mois pour un pistolet semi
automatique
ici on n'achète pas les armes on les
loue un nouveau business car opérait le
lieutenant-colonel manzoni le patron des
gendarmes de l'isle
bien de commerce de location d'armes
pour vol à main armée dont l épicerie
côté français au couteau landais
beaucoup d'argent mises à disposition et
vont servir par exemple à plusieurs
méfaits et en fait sont tout simplement
louer à la journée par leur propriétaire
pour faire tel ou tel fait louer une
arme à la journée rend plus difficile sa
traçabilité saint martin serait l'un des
territoires français les plus armés car
les pays voisins de l'île facilite leur
accès on est à une demi heure de porto
rico premier territoire des etats-unis
où l'accès à l'armement est libre là bas
donc on sait que par voie maritime ou
aérienne les armes circulent très
librement et on se rend compte
finalement
en étroite relation et aux caméras de la
police hollandaise que oui les armes
sont bel et bien là de par l'absence de
frontières